[Music]
this machine May hold the secrets to
time inside it scientists are looking
for the mysterious mechanism that
controls the daily biological clock
everything in your body is controlled on
this 24-hour process the things that
seems most interesting to me about
circadian biology is the fact that it
spands many time scales and many size
scales for more than a quarter of a
century
chronobiologists our biological clock
mechanisms trying to understand just
what makes them tick I mean I was hooked
as soon as I began graduate school I
really knew that I wanted to work to
unravel the molecular details of
circadian timing in 2020 Dr parch was
diagnosed with the neurodegenerative
disease ALS also known as Lou Garrick's
disease due to ALS my speeches beginning
to decline so use an AI clone of my
voice to give dogs and answer questions
like this but but she's still in search
of answers to how the clocks and
ourselves govern our days and nights I
believe we all need a purpose I can't
imagine not working also I really enjoy
the moment of Discovery in research
after putting in lots of thought and
hard work to be awarded with a
fundamental insight into life is about
as good as it
[Music]
gets chronobiologists study the effect
of time on biological Cycles those could
be as fast as a heartbeat or slow as a
seasonal animal Migration there's one
Rhythm most of us know intimately the
Circadian rhythm which governs a living
organism's 24-hour
clock this daily synchronization was
first observed in the early 1700s when a
French astronomer put a plant in a dark
room and watched it respond to the
cycles of day and night since then
researchers have been trying to decipher
just what sets the rhythm of these
clocks advances in DNA sequencing in the
1990s led to breakthroughs that began to
unravel the Myst
by identifying the genes that govern
circadian rhythms in 2017 a trio of
researchers were awarded the Nobel Prize
for their work on the molecular
mechanisms controlling fruit fly
circadian rhythms identifying the genes
required for timekeeping and
understanding how they work together in
a genetic network was an incredible step
forward for our field that was the end
of the story for many scientists but not
for all for people like Carrie and me
and other people in structural biology
there is another layer that I think we
really want to
know I'm really interested in the
molecular steps of these biological
clocks and how protein-based signals in
our cells can measure out a day the
circadian clock is triggered by the Sun
but it's not just about sleeping and
waking the Cadian clock also governs
more than 40% of human genes which
regulate Myriad other essential
functions including metabolism hormone
production and body temperature over the
course of the day in fact some medicines
like acetam metaphen are better
metabolized in the daytime and vaccines
can work differently depending on when
they are given in the morning or at
night many aspects of modern life like
traveling across time zones and exposure
to artificial light at night can wreak
havoc on our natural circadian clocks
but being out of sync with the natural
cycles can cause more than just fatigue
working the overnight shift is
associated with diabetes and heart
disease as well as certain cancers to
fix the mismatch between our bodies and
the modern world parch is searching for
ways to tweak the circadian clock but
first she had to map it for us to
understand sort of how the gears of the
clock turn we need to understand how the
proteins find one another how they
interact how long they stay together and
how that might be changed over time to
study the human biological clock at the
molecular level parches lab uses a
technique called nuclear magnetic
resonance spectroscopy or NMR NMR is
very highly related to MRI which many
people will know a lot more about what
NMR and MRI have in common is we both
need really big magnets in an NMR tank
liquid nitrogen and helium cool a
superconducting magnet which produces a
magnetic field a million times stronger
than Earth's so why do we do all that
that high magnetic field lets us be able
to detect signals coming off of many of
the atoms inside of the proteins or
drugs or DNA or RNA that we're putting
inside of a tube in the middle of the
magnet to study the biochemical and
biophysical mechanism of the circadian
rhythms we need to make proteins outside
the human body in test tubes we take the
DNA and we tell bacteria to do that for
us so this is the NMR tube we put it in
the magnet to take the reading using NMR
researchers like parch can see a picture
of proteins at work NMR is sort of like
taking a series of GPS snapshots of a
protein NMR gives us information about
the environment around certain atoms in
the protein and how they move which lets
us infer how the protein Wiggles around
in solution and responds to its Partners
like other proteins or drugs real power
of it is that all the work we do is
literally on samples in solution at room
temperature in parchers lab the samples
are often of what's called clock
proteins we call the proteins that
interact with each other and our genes
to regulate our circadian rhythms clock
proteins just like how the gears of a
mechanical clock work
together at the heart of the process are
two protein molecules called clock and
beol each day at dawn clock and beol
pair up in the cell cytoplasm before
entering the nucleus once inside they
bind to the DNA on thousands of sites to
regulate the production of proteins
important for daytime functions the
clock beam all pair also regulates the
production of two supressor proteins
period and cry which play a critical
role in their circadian feedback loop
levels of period and cry build up during
the day then at night they enter the
nucleus to strip clock beam all from the
DNA shutting things down over the course
of the Twilight hours the repressor
proteins Decay diminishing their effect
while the supply of clock and beol
proteins builds back up in the morning
the whole cycle begins again however
genetic variations can alter this
protein clock cycle leaving some out of
sync with the day and night light cycles
of
Earth one tiny change in a clock Gene an
inherited change that only Alters a few
atoms in the protein it encodes can
dramatically alter your internal clock
timing and change when you go to bed and
wake up I'm sure we all know some
morning Larks folks who go to bed early
and enjoy getting up with the Sun or
night owls who like staying up late well
some genetic changes Can Change clock
timing by hours leading to bed times at
5:00 p.m. or 4 a.m. by studying the
smallest components of our biological
clocks Arch's lab is searching for ways
to correct problems caused by genetics
or the intrusion of the modern world on
our circadian rhythms we're using NMR
now to discover and map how small
molecules bind to clock proteins with
the hope of turning these into drugs
that could help people adjust to shift
work or reduce jet lag or even treat
certain cancers like gleo blastoma that
depend on circadian
Machinery to parch the world is full of
clocks waiting to be pulled apart and
understood oh there is still so much
more to learn about our own clocks and
circadian rhythms in other species like
plants that could be important for
sustaining life on Earth and Beyond it's
exciting to see an awareness of
circadian biology and its impacts on our
health finally begin to grow in the
clinic hopefully we can build on this to
incorporate a better understanding of
how time influences our biology and
improve everything from our sleep to how
we respond to
[Music]
drugs